If you need more room at the hips and
tummy of your sweater when you shape the
side seams, you need to lengthen the
center front and back to keep them from
creeping up and being too short.
You do this by working short rows at the
lower edge, adding length in the center
and not at the side seams.
Let's say you want to add two inches
to the center back of your sweater.
Your gauge is six rows to the inch.
You'll want to add an additional
12 rows right here in the middle.
Here's a generic outline.
Start by casting on the required number of
stitches and work your ribbing or hem, or
however you're going
to finish your garment.
Then set your carriage to hold.
Pull a few stitches opposite the carriage
to hold position knit across and wrap.
Pull the same number of stitches
opposite the carriage to hold.
Knit across and rap.
Two rows have been knitted,
but none at the side seams.
Next, pull a few more stitches
to hold opposite the carriage.
Knit across and wrap.
Do it again on the other side.
A few more stitches to hold opposite
the carriage knit across, and wrap.
A total of four rows have
been knitted in the center.
Now repeat this for the total of the 12
rows tha you need for your two inches.
On the last row,
wrap for the last time and then put the
needles opposite the carriage into working
position.
Cancel.
Hold.
Reset your row counter and
continue following your pattern.
Notice that I left about a third of the
stitches in work at the center back.
You don't want to short row
to a point in the middle.
Now, if you want to be more precise,
you could do the math and work this out
perfectly.
I hope this has been
a helpful tip for you.
If you aren't familiar with working short
rows, they are a very powerful tool in
your knitting toolbox.
The learning library has quite a few
tutorials on using short rows, both
decorative uses and
practical ones like this.